No, the title isn't clickbait.
I actually went on basically a day trip from the East Coast to the West Coast just for a maid cafe.
Yep.
Welcome to Ton Tokoton Maid Cafe in Little Tokyo, Los Angeles.
It's based off of the maid cafe from the anime Akiba Maid Wars and is a collaboration between Hi-Dive, Saigames, Sentai Filmworks, and Akiba Pop-up and Live.
So I landed sometime around midnight the previous day and then the next day did literally nothing in my hotel room until it was time to head over to Little Tokyo.
I ended up being a little early to try and avoid too much traffic so it was fun to walk around and I saw that guy.
A week before the event, I was invited to join the opening day of the maid cafe and get a sneak peek of what it was going to be all about.
And you know, being the maid enthusiast I am, of course I had to answer the call.
It also feels like a rare opportunity to have these sorts of...
events pop up in the United States so I basically possessed a random person and made them go for me.
When it was time to go in, we were separated into tables and we had our maid greeting us the moment we walked in.
Look at you, Mechi!
She's so cute!
My first thought going in was just how authentic it felt.
You know, I've been to many many many many maid cafes and several collab cafes and not even most collab cafes are as dedicated as everyone here made it to be.
So it was really fun and really set the atmosphere and you can even see how the cafe is decorated to look just like the cafe from the show.
Which, you know, could be a good thing or I mean it's kind of like... dingy.
But it works, right?
That's how it was in the show!
They had different menus you could choose from for your food as well as entertainment menus.
But uh, you know, haha, baby's first vlog and unfortunately I forgot to get footage of that today, pero...
But uh, it included things such as check keys, also known as Polaroid photos, performances...
and games with the maids.
They also had original merch such as pen lights, t-shirts, stickers, and more!
The food was pretty standard for a maid cafe, though it was a little limited, which is understandable for a pop-up.
You could choose between the porker's omurice, heart-cune chicken curry, or piglet cutlet bento, which was a tonkatsu bento.
No one at my table got the curry, but the omurice and bento both included a drawing, which was really cute!
I asked for my maid's bento.
I wanted to draw a ghost maid.
But maybe I should have asked for a pig like everyone else at the table.
Oops.
There were also three types of drinks.
The oinky doink drink, the piggy pearl iced coffee, and the oinky doink water.
I thought based off the name, the coffee would have some jelly in it, but it was just plain coffee.
And I can't have soda, but if you can, I suggest the oinky doink drink because it comes with a cute little performance from your maid.
And each drink color ends up being different, so it's really fun.
I don't know what exactly is on the dessert menu, but we were given these really awesome ranco cookies.
And you can see that I got ice cream all over her face.
Oops.
What was so fun is all the Aikome!
It's also themed for the cafe.
Instead of your normal moi moi kyun, you're squealing like a pig saying buhi!
It's all really really sweet.
The best part by far was the performance though.
If you haven't watched the anime, be careful of spoilers.
But they basically did a quick rendition of the whole show for us, which is really really awesome.
It was so fun watching the maids go from violet gangsters to cutesy dancing idols.
And it was all songs from the anime, so it was really fun recognizing the opening song and the insert songs.
Everyone was so invested in their part and making it as authentic as possible.
I felt it was really worth it for the experience, and if you're in the LA area while it's still running, definitely check it out!
The cafe runs from June 28th to July 28th, and tickets are online only and reservation, so get your ticket before they sell out!
You can even see the cameraman from the cafe is dressed as the debt collector from the show.
Like come on, the level of effort was definitely there.
I also want to say, even though I was invited to go, I wasn't sponsored at all for this trip.
Everything was out of my pocket, so these are all my real feelings about it.
Overall, it was such a unique experience.
And if you've never been to Japan, or been to a major city, you should definitely check it out.
Or if you've been to a maid cafe and kind of want to compare your experiences between the two, definitely check it out.
Boo-hee!
Come on!